en fait le moment où vous avez passé le
plus de temps avec votre père c'est
quand il était malade
Sarah Giraudeau rebond soit
[Musique]
ça s'est bien passé ces vacances dans la
Creuse
alors ce que j'ai découvert en fait
c'est que les armoiries de la Creuse
c'était une coulant et le tabouret je
savais pas c'est gay comme blague non
c'est beau alors vous êtes la fille de
Bernard Giraudeau Annie Duperey vous
êtes donc double fille 2 donc ça vous
énerve doublement j'imagine quand on
vous en parlera
c'est vrai qu'il y a un poids du nom
dans une carrière par exemple si on
s'appelle Dutroux c'est dur de
travailler dans la petite enfance
alors vos parents ce sont séparés quand
vous aviez six ans
ils ont su garder d'excellents rapports
mais vous avez très peu vu ensemble en
fait très peu j'ai presque pas de
souvenir de mes parents ensemble mais
c'est pas grave
en fait le moment où vous avez passé le
plus de temps avec votre père c'est
quand il était malade
ça me rapproche la maladie
malheureusement vous dites sa tragédie
la révélé à lui-même
il est devenu vraiment lui-même on va
dire grâce
je peux dire à la maladie c'est horrible
à dire mais
c'est quand vous allez décider d'être
comédienne votre mère vous a fait
confiance votre père était plus réservé
il avait peur que vous souffriez
et puis un jour il y a eu le Molière
j'imagine que ça rattrapé 20 ans de
cadeaux pourri de la fête des pères non
pas du tout c'était une soirée
je viens de cette soirée-là mais faut
pas je l'ai pas pris plus que ça de
toute façon mon père m'avait dit
attention faut pas que tu le laisses
sinon
[Musique]
je voulais juste vous dire
que un comédien
comédien puisse rêver c'est faire rêver
les gens
et voilà j'embrasse j'embrasse très fort
mes parents ma mère qui est pas là mon
père
ici ce soir et j'en profite pour lui
dire que j'attends le moment je rêve du
moment où il va remonter sur scène
pense que je suis pas la seule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'aime papa
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui Sarah vous êtes sur la
scène du théâtre La Bruyère dans Zelda
et Scott au côté de Julien Boisselier et
Jean-Paul borde c'est l'histoire du
couple mythique des années 20 emportait
à l'image de l'Amérique par la
dépression il y a trois parties la
rencontre
dans tout ça avec de l'espoir est
beaucoup de notes d'humour c'est ce que
je trouve génial chez Renault Meyer
l'auteur et voilà c'est la passion entre
un lion de la littérature et s'amuse
endiablée on va dire qu'il va qui va
tourner au combat de fauve et à
l'autodestruction en sachant que ça
danse c'est très gai
comme ici
et pour finir la question de Laurent
Delahousse
[Musique]
ça va
pensez-vous que votre père serait fier
de vous aujourd'hui beaucoup je pense
avec un œil peut-être un petit peu plus
séduisant
vous seriez plus séduite par Laurent
delahoussement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu